where's the french connection now in
west africa troops are being withdrawn
from mali after a nine-year mission
other european countries also leaving so
who will fill the vacuum in a volatile
region and what does it mean for the
people of mali this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan nine years ago the people of mali
lined the streets to welcome french
troops who had arrived to stop an
insurrection but today waving a french
flag is seen as a symbol of colonialism
and oppression the relationship between
the two countries doesn't look like it's
getting any better
mali's military government expelled the
french ambassador to bamako after his
foreign minister called the junta
illegitimate and out of control
french troops are now preparing to quit
the country on the order of president
emmanuel macron
mali has also told danish soldiers to
leave and the continued presence of
german troops under a u.n peacekeeping
mission is in doubt
but russian private military contractors
from the wagner group are staying that's
leaving eu powers uneasy the contractors
are accused of exploiting mali's
resources in exchange for protecting the
junta
but malians are tired of the insecurity
in their country they say nine years of
french intervention has only served
european interests and they want an end
to the french connection
president emmanuel macron warned against
russian contractors stationed in mali
these mercenaries have been in libya for
years to capture resources and what
should go to the libyan people
they're actually leaving the country
they've been deployed in the central
african republic for several years and
have committed horrific crimes against
civilians that the un have reported
they're coming to mali with predatory
ambitions but why
because the junta and power in mali
after two coups
considers they are the best partners
they can find to consolidate their power
not to fight terrorism we'll introduce
our guests in a moment but first let's
look at the last decade of european
military intervention in the sahel
region in 2012 tuareg's separatists took
over large parts of northern mali
al-qaeda and iceland fighters also
entered the region
in january of the following year former
colonial power france sent in troops to
get rid of those groups but after
struggling for nine years france
announced it would end its operation
early in 2022.
danish soldiers of mali have also been
told to leave immediately and sweden
says its troops will leave in march in
germany members of parliament have
questioned the presence of its soldiers
in mali as part of the un peacekeeping
mission minousman
let's bring our guests into the show we
have joining us from samano in france
jacques rella he's a senior research
fellow at the global policy institute
from accra in ghana cuakodanso is a
research fellow at the kofi annan
international peacekeeping training
center and on the line from bamako in
mali we're joined by nyan corolla samake
a politician and former diplomat welcome
to you all if i could start with quaker
so
why have relations broken down quaker
between mali and france thank you very
much well i think for a number of
reasons
first of all i think the french
presidency in mali
has become increasingly unpopular
since the deployment of the 4cc mali
you know the number of
violent extremist attacks
have been on a steady increase
and people have the perception that
french with all the sophisticated
military capacities that it has
should be able to
address that situation
but this has not been the case and
people's expectations have not been met
even so kwaku even if the french are not
performing as malians hoped the rather
bitter exchange
of words is something else isn't it
how do we explain that
yes so relationship between the two
partners
if i can call them parties but uh
with jamie mali
and
harry have been strained in recent times
particularly
uh given the refusal
of the janta in mali to comply with
regional norms and principles
to return the country into
constitutional
rule
so
aside from that the emergence of the
wagner group on the scene
is a development that is not acceptable
to the french
who
are not prepared to cohabitate with
these insurgents not insurgent but then
mercenaries
so that
strange relationship has been at the
heart of the recent development and
therefore the decision of the french to
pull out they've also had some words to
say french have some words to say about
the legitimacy of those in charge of
mali right now who came to power through
a coup jacques in france
why can france work with an
administration which came to power
through a coup in chad but not mali why
can they work well they're accused of
working to support khalifa hafta who's
also backed by the wagner group and that
can work in libya
but the similar scenario doesn't work in
mali why
it's a good question
indeed because it shows that that's one
of the reasons why there's this
anti-french feeling feeling that france
is playing a double game is the fact
that france tries to promote the idea of
democratically democratic governments
imposes democratic conditions
on
governments it wants to help while at
the same time
uh
backing
the coup
in in chad when the president uh debbie
uh was killed died uh his son replaced
him without an election and so on and
the french said amen do that so uh it's
true and but the situation in in mali
is that is slightly different france was
very present in money and at the same
the government that came through to the
two pouches of 2020 and 2021
were promised to all the elections after
uh
by already this year normally we should
have an election this year i've decided
it would keep power for five years and
they had the feeling that uh this
junta in power
with the president maga and goethe
have
definitely are
keen on getting rid of the french that
they want to put an end to the french
president they made the the cooperation
impossible uh with between or very
difficult between the french forces and
the median army and therefore uh i think
that now they've approached
actually they're
keener to for a rough rush more with
russia at the moment it's not officially
with russia but let's not forget that
when mali became independent in 1961
they
were backed strongly by the soviet union
of the time and the
some of their generals are actually have
been trained with by the russian army so
they are close links with the russian
army and they thought that actually uh
maybe there there was a
behind it uh an attempt maybe to change
around within uh uh by money and
therefore that not welcomed anymore they
could see that the the anti-french
feeling was developing in the country
which had been whipped up by social
networks and by the current the current
authorities it made their situation
untenable having been an army of
liberation they are now considered as an
army of occupation they're accused of
promoting the partition of the country
uh
following events like going back to uh
in kidan when the french
cleared the jihadist the kidah area but
did not allow
the malian troops to intervene so france
is accused of double standards but at
the same time there had been the
accusation that they were not fighting
jaidism is completely wrong because
they've had quite a lot of success on
the ground the problem for france now is
that
jainism yes they are they have some
military success it's not a military
failure at all it's a political failure
what's happening is that in spite of the
fight against jihadism islamism is
spreading through malayan society along
with uh the anti-french figure all right
we'll cover we'll talk in a minute more
about whether or not it's
perceived as a military uh victory or
failure
but if we can bring nian coro into the
discussion why have those who are in
power in mali right now why are they
leaning more towards apparently at least
this russian mercenary group or other
powers and away from france
well
the number one reason would be resolved
we
after nine years of failed policies
military strategies
um malians have you know been burying
our
civilians and military personnel
we wanted to diversify our partnership
and france didn't see this by to i and
they played a partialistic role saying
that we dictate to a sovereign nation
what we think is right or not right all
right but i'm sure you're aware if i can
jump in the anchor i'm sure malian
authorities are aware of the accusations
surrounding some of the operations of
wagner groups in the central african
republic in in in other places
and allegations
of human rights abuses if the feeling in
mali was we need we're tired of burying
our civilians
are those that the marines are now
looking at really the solution to end
abuse of civilians
um you know the french troops have
committed horrific
actions against civilians in mali and
recently and it has happened in bunti
where they kill people celebrating
weddings
and
you know it horrific crimes are crimes
that look into depending on who
committed so we don't think that that
dichotomy will work
well in this situation so this is not
about
uh
the nationality or superpowers playing
the role we want security we want to
secure our borders we want to secure our
people so the decisions coming from our
authorities are not based on how france
perceives who our partners are not this
is based on how can we get rid of the
violent uh crime that are being
committed in the northern part and in
the center of mali and the decision is
solely based on that and we want
partnership where where the people of
mali are respected where the authorities
are respected
and those are some of the things that
led to the the breakout the breakup
between mali and the french authorities
all right let me bring quacker back into
the discussion
is french evolving uh french policy
towards west africa evolving i mean
there was a time
when if france didn't like a government
there would be a coup and france would
be accused of orchestrating it right
now we're just seeing them walk away
at least militarily
well so i think the difference between
the two scenarios is the fact that
the actors
in the theater simply
do not appear to have a harmony of
interest
so previously
regime whether it was through a military
intervention or not
that was sustained
by france was a regime that had some
sort of harmony of interest but in this
case it appears the harmony of interest
between
korea and bamako
is missing rather
i think the wagner group and for that
matter
russia appeared to provide them with
multiple choices that otherwise was
lacking
so is french influence decreasing do you
think
do you think french interest
do you think french influence is
decreasing kwaku
well i think the french influence over
the year has uh win has declined
and part of it relates to the results
that my other colleague spoke about and
also there's this perception that
there is uh
you know
france has an interest
in having the regime
or the government in mali need them
and that explains the reason why they
have not been very committed
in bringing the insurgencies and
extremist
attacks to an end because for so long as
the violence persists that so long can
you expect to have the french in the
region and so all these
perceptions have combined to
influence the decision being taken by
the regime and for that matter all right
the relationship between paris and burma
jacques do you think the french
withdrawal is going to leave a vacuum
that anyone else can fill can
the wagner group fill that
vacuum no the fact that you can't feel
that vacuum that's uh that's for sure uh
what's going to happen after that that's
a big question uh first i would like
also to add that if the situation is
very difficult in uh in mali it's not
just due to the french
there is a there's been a big failure of
governance and we know that
the army
has been accused of executions by its
people
that there's a lot of corruption that
public services are not present on the
ground so as a result of that the
influence of grd's groups the
development of sharia as a way to
administer justice in the area is
spreading as a result of the failure of
the million states and that's why this
failure the failure of mali is more
political failure than a military
failure you can't accuse the french of
not having uh killed enough jihadists
they've done the job in that sense the
problem is that the million state hasn't
followed and now
that we have this junta in power who
calls on wagner not to help mali so much
but to protect them to be able to enable
them to stay in power to protect them
from further coups that's the main aim
well okay france africa now of the the
old
france africa the seventies eighties
nineties under mitheron shirak and all
that the close links it's coming to an
end and macron wants it but at the same
time the main interest for france is to
protect the countries which are
economically uh very powerful such as
the ivory coast and protect countries uh
and benign and on the on the guinea on
the gulf of guinea and that's why the
french are not withdrawing they're
relocating and they're relocating based
on let me jump to jack because you
mentioned a very important point there
which is the failure of the state let me
take that point to nyankoro are the
authorities in mali overlooking what
jack is analyzing there that a big part
of the problem is the failure of the
state to uh provide good governance for
its people that's why uh armed groups
are increasing in their influence
you know it's a total misconception of
what is going on and that is the mistake
that many are making
yes we need better governance in mali
but the security situation the mandate
under which french troops are in mali
here they are the reason why menisma or
the u.n
peacekeeping forces are here they have a
clearly defined
mandate and of course french has failed
to provide
uh the terms of its mandate for being
here in mali containing jihadis
preventing protecting the people and
helping the government of mali
restructure
our military
the fundamental reason is we have
failure of governance and that's why the
hunter came into power
following six months of protests of
millions of millions demanding better
governance and france yes has come and
praised the first part of this
transition saying that they've done in
three months what the seven years of
previous governance has done but the
minute the transition authorities have
decided that they know what's best for
our people and they're protecting the
best interests of people let me pose
this question to you though
if the security job wasn't being done
properly with the french who will do it
better without the french who will i
mean the french did provide
an ability or a network for
several countries to work together
across borders right
nigeria cameroon chad
you know
we did not ask the french to leave the
french decided to leave because they
don't want to work with us under our
terms they want to dictate the terms of
uh partnering with us and that is the
reason why they have authorities did
call upon them to leave as soon as
possible though as well didn't they
after they decided to leave and they
said we're going to live within certain
number of months and that is that was
not acceptable for the people of uh the
government of mali and the people of
bali so our will should be respected if
you want to break unilaterally your
relationship with us you do it
responsibly and take out and not say
we're going to prolong our stay while
you're telling the whole world that you
have decided to leave mali and that does
not work either but coming back to the
the primary question of whether uh what
the french needs what will happen mali
head has ports of other partnerships
that we will develop will work inside
and our army today is actually
doing the job they are retaking the
bases that france has left they we are
containing and pushing on the resilience
right now as it has never happened
before
okay let me jump into it and see jacques
is shaking his head in disagreement let
me give him a brief opportunity to come
in on that jack go ahead
i'm amazed at what i hear you know it's
uh
it's so
removed from
so far from from the truth saying that
now the indian army etc is doing a great
uh fight against uh
geodes in the north and so on no it's
you know it's not true but okay now they
say they're making progress
they say they make progress
maybe
and this is this denial is not going to
help the situation this is a
let's give 10 seconds to jack to finish
up his comments uninterrupted and then
we'll come back to you nian cora go
ahead john but
at the same time france is not uh
abandoning the fight against uh uh
giada's terrorism in the area they are
relocating they are going to be acting
uh from
from niger and from chad and therefore
will be will retain they have many bases
in the area are going as far off as they
are very cool but some chad in niger in
in burkina faso
his point of view is very biased and
unreal we are on the ground here this is
about mali uh no one is going to tell us
what's working and what's not that's the
reason why we first of all expel the the
ambassador of france to mali because of
the lack of respect and the
paternalistic uh partnership that uh the
french government we don't have anything
against the french people but the
government's behavior and the policy
that they're having africa is changing
and they may or may not have refuge in
those countries okay all right you've
made the point clear clearly there are
different perspectives on what's
happening on the ground let's take it if
we can now to kwaku and ask this
question the bigger picture
is there a cycle of deterioration
of life for people in mali is that the
big picture here security
was a challenge
there's been a coup
none of that can be good for the economy
none of that can be good for governance
right civilian authorities pushed out
people were unhappy even with civilian
authority yes so
the issue of governance remains a major
challenge and
it is
at the heart of most of the other
challenges we are witnesses with
witnessing which are basically a
manifestation
of the
you know governance crisis across the
continent
but yet again i think we need to look
beyond just the internal dynamics
critical as
critical global factors are we also need
to look at the system-wide challenges
right
particularly looking at so we were
talking about
french the french presence earlier um to
what extent has the french contributed
in enhancing issues of
governance in mali i think the friends
have had
a lot of influence over the leadership
in mali since independence
but then to what extent
have their contribution help in terms of
enhancing governance in the country and
therefore preventing
uh development such as crudites and so
on and so forth because i think one is
one significant factor we should take
into account is the fact that the recent
crews that have happened in mali in
burkina faso in guinea and other places
have been cools that are very popular
and for me that is particularly
troubling
if you have a good eater that is
receiving massive support from the
population then it tells you there's a
lot that is uh problematic with the
style of governance that we have in the
region and i think we need a systemic
approach to addressing uh the problem
the fact that the french have been on
the ground
for the system the past night
to solving the problems let's end on
that note slightly
optimistic one looking forward let's
hope they find that approach that helps
solve some of those problems in a more
effective way for now we are out of time
so we're going to have to thank our
guests thank you very much to nyankoro
yeah
jacques
and kwaku
and thank you two for watching you can
see the show again any time by visiting
our website aljazeera.com
for further discussion head over to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle there is at aj inside story
from me sami zaidan and the whole team
here in doha for now is goodbye